food options are limited for many in
Lebanon affected by the collapse of its
economy
many items are now crossed off from
their shopping lists
I used to buy three or four kilos of
tomatoes now it's one or even half a
kilo everything changed I can't afford
meat or chicken we are only buying
Essentials
the collapse of the local currency has
affected people's purchasing power the
world food program says the average
salary in Lebanon now covers 24 percent
of basic food needs
it's helping feed one in three Lebanese
for the past two years the situation is
catastrophic the currency's devaluation
hurt us we used to eat two meals a day
now we barely can afford one and it's
potatoes most of the time we spend it
three times more than our income
for goods have since flooded the market
but despite that food prices increased
30 percent this year and more than one
thousand five hundred percent since the
economic crisis began in 2019.
we used to buy goods from the west but
people couldn't pay one dollar for a
chocolate bar now we import from turkey
and Syria because it's cheaper
the political class blamed for decades
of bad policies and Corruption is
failing to address the crisis the
situation could get worse as the country
heads to what could be an extended
political vacuum
Parliament failed to elect a successor
to president michelown who leaves office
at the end of the month it won't be the
first time the country has been without
a leader but this time around there's
likely to be no government to take on
executive powers
this is no longer a middle-income
country and there's little social
justice many like Ahmed simul have no
social protection and are forced to find
any way they can to survive the new
reality Beirut